special thanks to athletic greens the
ultimate all-in-one nutritional
supplement for supporting this video
please see the link in the description
to learn more
i've always been very type a and so a
friend of mine got me into cycling
when i was living in l.a and i lived
right on the beach in santa monica where
there's this great
bike path in the sand that goes for i
think it's 25 miles
in the sand uh 25 no hold on something
like that the exact number doesn't
matter
but what i would do is i would go onto
the bike path and i would
get like head down and push it as hard
as i could i would go
all the way to one end of the bike path
and back and then back home and i'd set
my little timer when doing this
huffing and puffing red faces yeah just
red face huffing it but like just
pushing it as hard as i can every single
you know thrust of the leg
and uh of course you know that made me
quite fun if somebody was
in my way on the bike path sure that
guy's got places to go
so but i noticed it was always 43
minutes i mean you know if you know
santa monica california you know the
weather is about
exactly the same all year round so
unless it was a surprisingly windy day
it was always
43 minutes is what it took me to go as
fast as i could
for that on that bike path but i noticed
that over time
i was starting to feel less
psyched about going out on the bike path
because just mentally when i would think
of it it would feel like
pain and hard work it sounds like pain
and hard work
yeah i mean it was but you know it i
guess at first
that was okay and after a while i just
felt like i don't know riding the bike
why don't i just hang out
um so then i said you know that's no
that's not cool for me to
start to associate negative stuff with
going on the bike ride
why don't i just chill for once like i'm
just gonna go on the same bike ride
but just you know i'm not going to be a
complete snail but i'll go at like half
of my normal pace
so yeah i got on my bike and it was just
pleasant
i just went on the same bike ride but i
was more like standing up and i just
noticed that i was
i was looking around more and and i
looked down in the ocean i noticed there
was
that day there were these dolphins
jumping in the ocean and
and i went down to marina del rey to my
turn around point
and um oh no actually it was when the
the breakers at marina
del rey there was a penguin that was
flying above me i was like no way i
looked up i was like
hey a penguin and he [ __ ] in my mouth
[Laughter]
was it a penguin or a pelican oh sorry
pelicans
flying penguin above my head that would
be more amazing
i was like what what did you take before
your ride so you see it a pelican
pelican [ __ ] in your mouth that's
incredible accuracy was that from like
how far away was it
uh like 20 feet up wow because i i don't
know if he was accurate or i was you
know
anyway so the point is
i i had such a nice time it was just
purely pleasant
there was no red face there was no
huffing and puffing i was just cycling
it was nice
and when i got back to my usual stopping
place
i looked at my watch and it said 45
minutes
and i was like no way how the hell could
that have been 45 minutes as compared to
my usual 43.
it's like there's no way but yeah it was
right 45 minutes
and that was like a profound lesson
that i think changed the way i've
approached my life ever since
it's because i realized that i guess you
know what percentage of that huffing and
puffing then
we could do the math or whatever with a
93 point something percent of my huffing
and puffing
and all that red face and all that
stress was only for
an extra two minutes it was basically
for nothing i mean you know of course
we're not talking about me competing in
something where the huffing and puffing
might have been worth it but
for life i think of all of this
optimization and getting the maximum
dollar out of everything in the maximum
out of every second of the maximum
amount of every minute
and i think i just take this approach
now of going like or you could just
take the lesson take most of that lesson
and apply it and be effective and be
happy
you don't need to stress about any of
this stuff and so honestly that's been
my approach ever since i do things but i
stop
before anything gets stressful
i get asked all the time what i would
take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance i recommended it in fact
in the four hour body this is more than
10 years ago and i did not get paid to
do so
with approximately 75 vitamins minerals
and whole foods sourced ingredients
you'd be very hard pressed to find a
more nutrient-dense and comprehensive
formula on the market it has multi
vitamins
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it
once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i focus on nutrient-dense meals
to begin with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around it's also nsf
certified for sport making it safe for
competitive athletes
as what's on the label is in the powder
it is the ultimate all-in-one
nutritional supplement bundle
in one easy scoop and right now athletic
greens is giving my audience that's you
guys
a special offer on top of their
all-in-one formula which is a free
vitamin d supplement with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d
which is usually produced in our bodies
from sun exposure so
particularly in the winter months adding
a vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support
make an investment in your health today
and try the ultimate all-in-one wellness
bundle
support your immunity gut health and
energy by visiting athleticgreens.com
tfs you'll receive up to a year's supply
of
vitamin d for free with your first
subscription purchase again
that's athleticgreens.com tfs
as in tim ferriss show
athleticgreens.com
tfs